YouTube might be best known for short viral
clips.
But you may not know that YouTube also offers
thousands of free movies as well.
Yes, on YouTube you can watch everything from
indie films uploaded by their creators, to
modern movies released for free by major studios,
to classic films that are now in the public
domain.
In fact, there are so many options it can
be hard to know where to start.
That's why we've put together this list of
some of the best free movies on YouTube.
Kung Fury
This comedy-action indie was produced as a
tribute to the awesome action films of the
1980s.
In the film, a Miami detective is simultaneously
struck by lightning and bitten by a cobra
— which, obviously, gives him superhuman
Kung Fu powers.
"Game over."
He uses the new power granted to him to clean
up the streets of Miami.
But our hero faces his worst adversary yet
when he comes face-to-face with Kung Fu master...Adolf
Hitler.
Ka-pow!
Margot at the Wedding
This dark comedy follows the story of Margot
and her son Claude as they visit Margot's
sister Pauline for her wedding to the unsuccessful
artist and musician Malcolm.
"Expectation just turns to disappointment
so ultimately I'd rather not share."
But the plot is secondary to the awesome cast:
it features Nicole Kidman as Margot, Jennifer
Jason-Leigh as Pauline, and a hilarious performance
from Jack Black in the role of the unmotivated
and socially inept Malcolm.
It's a winner.
Four Horsemen
In this independent British documentary, the
filmmakers take a hard look at current banking
and economic practices in Western countries,
as well as the War on Terror, and how it all
connects to our monetary policies.
Time Out London critic Derek Adams wrote:
"Instead of bombarding us with sensational
imagery and scaremongering, this competently
narrated, intelligibly structured and cleverly
illustrated film presents its case via a succession
of insights from a group of smart, rational
orators."
In other words, it's not exactly your typical
YouTube video…
"Leave me alone, please."
Slacker
Not to be confused with the 2002 movie Slackers,
this 1991 independent comedy-drama marked
the directorial debut of Richard Linklater,
who would go on to direct classics like Boyhood
and Dazed and Confused.
"That's what I like about these high school
girls, man.
I get older they stay the same age."
Featuring a uniquely unstructured storyline,
Slacker is a slice of time—a day in the
life of multiple 20-something misfits as they
drift through Austin, Texas.
Shot with a single 16mm camera on a micro
budget of just $23,000, many filmmakers — including
Kevin Smith — have cited Slacker as a major
source of inspiration and the start of the
'90s independent movie movement.
"The people they need, like scientist, you
heard about that.
All the missing scientist around the world
and those that mysteriously dying.
That's all part of the recruiting process.
I really hope you friend is not, well.
They need a lot of lackeys to do the labor
though.
So they will be looking for ordinary guys.
You know, like you and me."
Funny About Love
While Funny About Love was pretty much universally
panned by critics upon its release, it might
deserve another look.
Why?
Well, it was directed by the legendary Leonard
Nimoy, stars the late, great Gene Wilder,
and has an interesting take on the whole "ticking
biological clock" trope — but from a man's
perspective.
Wilder's comedic genius shines through in
several places, making Funny About Love a
good pick for a cheap date night flick.
"Take this, take this thing"
Night of the Living Dead
Considered by many to be the seminal zombie
movie, Night of the Living Dead has been massively
influential on the horror genre in the decades
since its release.
George A. Romero's directorial debut is more
atmospheric than most modern zombie films,
focusing instead on the effects of a zombie
outbreak in a small town, with most of the
film is set within the house where the cast
members take refuge.
"I ought to drag you out there and feed you
those things."
Walking Dead's got nothing on this…
"Liar"
Nosferatu
F.W. Murnau's 1922 silent classic Nosferatu
is required watching material for all horror
fans.
The earliest surviving example of a major
vampire film, actor Max Schreck delivers a
mesmerizing performance as the ghastly vampire
in this unauthorized adaptation of Bram Stoker's
Dracula.
It's amazing the movie even exists, as a court
once ordered all copies to be destroyed after
Stoker's estate sued for copyright infringement.
But loyal fans secretly saved it and passed
copies around — making it one of the first
true viral videos ever.
Only fitting for the original bed intruder…
"So y'all need to hide yo kids, hide yo wife
and hide yo husband because they rapping everybody
out here."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
free YouTube film you'd recommend…